le congrès maghrébin au québec et
annonce l'ouverture des candidatures son
concours les voies du succès c'est un
vous bien sûr du grand gala qui s'en
vient le 21 octobre
cinquième de l'édition gala cmq marianne
louis martin a souri et la présidente du
congrès des maghrébins au québec et les
monts éviter bonjour brillamment la
table c'est déjà la cinquième édition
c'est c'est donc une pérennité dans
l'événement
en fait c'est devenu une tradition au
congrès de célébrer chaque année
l'excellence maghrébine au québec et de
fêter et de sortir de l'ombre des
québécois d'origine maghrébine dans
différents domaines que ce soit demain
professionnels entrepreneuriales
leadership féminin art et culture on a
des catégories nouvelles cette année
puis c'est dans la continuité mais avec
aussi une note une vision un peu je
dirais une nouvelle mais dans la
continuité toujours avec les événements
qu'on a connu québec notamment
l'histoire du cimetière les terribles
événements de la mosquée lincendie de la
voiture et j'en parle c'est combien
d'autres et les regards ensuite c'est ce
sont des défis quotidiens qui s'installe
qui sont présents et il y encore
beaucoup plus présent vous avez tout à
fait raison mais moi je sors la tête de
tout ça pour dire que par ailleurs on
reste des citoyens canadiens et des
québécois d'origine maghrébine veut veut
pas et avec ça on compose c'est pour
cela le gala cette année une voie du
succès on veut célébrer le succès dans
tout ça on voudrait avoir une vision
positive et de pouvoir redonner
confiance et incertain
dynamisme positive à la communauté
surtout moi je parle du congrès
maghrébin en 2000 membres et
sympathisants et des gens qui souvent le
cmq un organisme qui répondent à
certains besoins qui sont au niveau
professionnel entrepreneuriat et un
pouvoir d'impact au niveau pignon
qu'elles sont des effets qu'on peut
avoir sur la générations subséquentes
ceux qui sont nés ici mais qui portent
des noms tels djouhri est instituée
écoutez moi je ne savent vraiment pas
pas dans ces discussions là parce que du
moment que on a décidé de venir d'ici à
une décision c'est un choix on l'a fait
la démarche
je pense que tout autour de ça pourrait
être que des défis qu'il faut surmonter
est-ce que la plus grande décision
qu'elle gens pressés de quitter chez eux
pour aller bâtir chez eux aussi indiqué
l'édition partir s'installer aussi j'ai
dit que lorsqu'on décide de dire que est
ici c'est chez nous il a pu continuer
personnel de personnes dans le monde qui
ont cette chance de dire moi je décide
de devenir canadiens et québécois à
manger à leur choix c'est ça c'est un
choix donc si je sais je trouve que moi
c'est une opportunité unique dans la vie
et moi c'est comme ça que j'essaye de le
véhiculer puisque je le vis comme sam
avec les défis que que ça représente
mettons de dear maria maggiore 60 pas un
trop beau mais ça ne fait pas de moi une
personne différente de quelqu'un qui
paie ses impôts qui se réveille le matin
qui ramait six enfants à l'école puis
parce que la journée dans ses bureaux à
servir ses clients et qui essaie de
donner quelque chose à la communauté par
ailleurs laissé aucun aussi temps des
liens vers
les politiques les niveaux peuvent aussi
vers les gens d'affaires développe des
partenariats on développe des pistes
d'analysé on développe également des
pistes de réflexion
écoutez le simple de personnes
l'histoire de il a été créé en 2009 et
la nomination déjà du congrès à ce poids
et cette effet d'impact positif dans le
sens où lorsque par exemple un sujet qui
touche les immigrants général on est
sollicité à donner notre opinion on
dépose les mémoires
les pro active avec ce qui se passe sur
la scène politique tout en étant
apolitique donc peu importe avec qui qui
en place notre objectif c'est de faire
avancer les dossiers et les sujets qui
touchent à notre communauté
moi le tournant que j'essaie de donner à
sa tout en gardant ce set
c'est un pacte l'un ses devoirs de me
diriger vers les magali bas je dirais
québécois d'origine maghrébine qui
aujourd'hui tiennent des positions de
décision ou ceux qui sont en chemin qui
personnes pour leur carrière dans les
organisations pays dès lors dire bah
écoutez en ce seul et des québécois à
part entière puis venons le manifester
puis il une façon de les manier si c'est
de faire d'abord cette manifestation de
l'excellence de dire bravo mais hier par
exemple il y avait une conne et la
turquie est tombé avec un courriel de 5
par agréable dans lequel de monsieur en
question il dit cette démarche m'a
permis d'abord de me connaître de
prendre le temps même si une personne 2
et 10 activement sa carrière mais de
prendre le temps de réfléchir on n'a pas
ce que j'ai réalisé et de la presse ipi
il a trouvé c'est un exercice difficile
les gens ne prennent pas le temps de le
faire c'est pour ça que je lance le
l'invitation aux québécois d'origine
maghrébine de prendre le temps de se
dire bravo par rapport à ce qu'ils ont
ri
le souligne une façon de le souligner
c'est de les partager
pour inspirer les autres ça mon objectif
c'est vraiment inspiré les autres et de
leur donner l'espoir que ça marche et ça
peut marcher peu importe les défis et
les résoudre il est ce qu'on peut
proposer une candidature
l'exercice personnel moi même je les
fais en 2004 j'étais l'oreillette 2015
et je suis rendue aujourd'hui le
président des congrès et j'avoue que
comme comme ce monsieur là qui nous a
écrit disons que je trouvais la démarche
intéressante et j'invite les gens à le
faire c'est qu'on suivait l'horizon
qu'il que c'est dans le sens que moi je
me dis mais aussi une réalisation voici
pourquoi je pense que je suis un
candidat parfait pour ce gala est
pourquoi je pense que je peux être me
rien et cd merci d'abord une box
nouvelle valorisation interne et après
on réalise je pense avec le chemin qu'on
a fait puis je pense le débat va être
juste une soirée d'inspiration et de
partage magnifique et de voir des
visages des sourires mais surtout cet
espoir là pour nos enfants
est-ce que c'est dans la continuité
c'est un papa une maman qui réussit dans
un gala qui se faire connaître parce que
pouvoir la reconnaissance très
importante que ce soir il reconnaissait
ce personnel par les employeurs par la
communauté par d'affaires par les
communautés sociales et sociétales tout
court
c'est un exercice intéressant que je
trouve et moi je ne voudrais pas
d'efforts pour que ça réussisse
l'idée est face à va pas sans ça c'est
un 10 les graines ou même les voies du
succès c'est wait and see
à montréal c'est dans un petit mois en
fait c'est le 21 on est en mode pour
préparatifs déjà à lille s'était
définitivement
ça fait déjà plusieurs mois qu'on
travaille là dessus et en tout cas on a
des partenaires vraiment de poids je
pourrais pas les mêmes et les la
question de publicité mais je suis
vraiment fier des personnes qui m'ont
fait confiance qui ont fait confiance au
congrès et qui ont décidé de se joindre
à nous pour en fait faire de ce gala un
succès tel que les le mans 2 du gala
mais votre succès c'est le gala 2010
cette scène guy le congrès des
maghrébins au québec mariama jury a mené
la présidente
je vous souhaite un méga mots de gros
travail france habitation d'être parmi
nous ce soir là merci beaucoup aussi